[музыка]
Представьте себе компанию, которая была
оценена в 47 млрд долларов и готовилась
к триумфальному IPO, но рухнула почти за
одну ночь. Во многом это произошло,
потому что её основатель уверовал в
собственную непогрешимость. Звучит как
миф о Бикаре, который взлетел слишком
близко к солнцу и обжёг свои крылья. Вы
скажете, такого не бывает? Или это
нереально в жизни? К сожалению, это
самая настоящая правда, и это не самый
большой провал в истории. И всему виной
наше эго. Недаром древняя мудрость
гласит: "Гордыня предшествует погибели,
а надменность падению". Эго, чрезмерная
гордость и самомнение не раз становились
причиной громких провалов. От легенд о
гибельной самонадейности до краха целых
государств и корпораций XXI века.
История учит нас одному. Когда эго
принимает решение, беда не за горами. Но
что, если мы сумеем отключить своё эго
при принятии важных решений? Что если мы
будем принимать решения без привязки к
личным амбициям и обидам? В этом видео
мы проведём глубокое исследование
дегоизации процесса принятия решений от
философских трактатов стоиков,
религиозной и народной мудрости до
современных научных исследований и
кейсов из бизнеса. Вы узнаете, как
осознанность и смирение помогают
избегать когнитивных ловушек. И почему
эго - это наш самый большой враг? Как
лучшие лидеры добиваются успеха, убирая
своё эго с дороги? Мы разберём
практические инструменты дегоизации
процесса принятия решений, и вы поймёте,
как принимать мудрые решения в своей
жизни и бизнесе. Это шестое видео из
цикла моих роликов о суперпозиции.
Суперпозиция - это стратегия по созданию
такой ситуации, при которой всё, что
происходит, идёт вам на пользу. Вам
закономерно везёт, и вы извлекаете из
этого максимальный эффект. Это видео
будет полезно всем людям, но особенно
оно будет полезно руководителям всех
уровней, независимо от того, бизнес -
это политика или инвестиции. Досмотрите
это видео до конца, и вы найдёте
источник своих ошибок и провалов, а
также научитесь принимать решения более
осознанно и мудро. Подписывайтесь на мой
канал, жмите на колокольчик, активно
комментируйте и делитесь этим видео с
людьми, которых вы считаете
амбициозными. Поверьте, они будут вам
очень
благодарны. Если же вы хотите получать
больше таких знаний, подписывайтесь на
мой Telegram-канал, где я делюсь многими
своими инсайтами.
Ну что, готовы обезвредить своего
внутреннего врага и саботажника? Тогда
[музыка]
поехали. Идея обуздания эго уходят в
глупь веков. Старицизм учит смирению и
трезвой оценке себя. Стойки видели в эго
источник страданий и ошибок. Марк
Аврелий ежедневно напоминал себе не
поддаваться высокомерию. Сенека, будучи
богатым, нарочно практиковал жизнь в
бедности, чтобы сохранить свой разум.
Они верили, что смирение убивает опасную
гордыню, пока гордыня не уничтожила всё,
что им дорого. Как пишет современный
исследователь, эго постоянно сравнивает
себя с другими и вступает в бесконечное
соперничество. Стаицизм же - это способ
ослабить эго и стать более
сострадательным и скромным. Не только
западные мудрецы предупреждали о
ловушках эго. В буддизме считается, что
устойчивое я - это иллюзия, а
привязанность к эго - это источник
страданий. Будда учил отпускать
эгоистичные желания, чтобы достичь
просветления. Буддийская мудрость
гласит: "Привязанность к эго -
фундаментальное невежество, причиняющее
человеческие страдания". Если нет
раздутого чувства собственной важности,
то и обиды гаснут. Как сказано в тексте,
мы бы избежали столько конфликтов, если
бы отпустили потребность постоянно
защищать себя. В Конфуцианстве смирение
- это добродетель. Конфукций говорил:
"Истинное знание - это осознание степени
собственного невежества. Это даёт
простор для роста и удерживает эго в
узде". Он презирал хвостовство и пустую
гордость. "Благородный муж скромен в
речах, но усерден в делах", - говорил
он.
Гордыня осуждается веками. В народе есть
поговорки: "Чем выше взлетишь, тем
больнее падать. Возгордившийся будет
унижен". В книге притчи и Соломоновых
сказано: "Гордость предшествует
разрушению, а надменность падению". В
христианстве из семи смертных грехов
человека гордыня стоит на первом месте и
считается самым тяжким из грехов.
Христос даже умыл ноги своим ученикам,
показывая пример скромности. Яков
наставлял: "Бог противится гордым, но
смиренным даёт
благодать". "Кто превозносится, тот
унижен будет, а кто смиряется, будет
возвышен". Говорится в Евангелии от
Луки. Ислам очень сильно осуждает
гордыню. В Коране говорится: "Не ходи по
земле надменно. Аллах не любит надменных
хвостунов". Пророк Мухаммад саллаллаху
алейхи ва саллям учил, что смирение
возвышает человека, что в сердце
верующего не должно быть и крупицы
высокомерия. Легенда о падении Иблиса
или сатаны в исламе подчёркивает, что
именно гордыня сделала его изгнанником.
Народные притчи подтверждают все эти
уроки. В басне Андерсона про голого
короля король, ослеплённый гордыней и
лестью, марширует ногишом перед
подданными, воображая себя в
великолепном наряде. В мифе о нарциссе
юноша, влюблённый в своё отражение,
погибает. Везде гордыня ведёт к падению.
Скромность украшает человека, - говорили
наши бабушки. Пословица и народная
мудрость сходятся. Не говори Гоп, пока
не перепрыгнул яму. Психолог Карл Юнг
писал: "Из-за гордости мы постоянно
обманываем сами себя. Наше эго строит
иллюзии, а смирение помогает увидеть
истину". Итак, от библейских времён до
наших дней народная мудрость сходится с
философией и религией. Эго - это путь к
ошибке и позору, а смирение ведёт к
возвышению. История учит. Тот, кто
смиренно принимает реальность и избежит
бед. Напишите в комментариях, были ли в
вашей жизни случаи, когда эго мешало
или, наоборот, смирение помогало вам.
Поделитесь, пожалуйста, своим опытом.
Мне будет интересно
почитать. Древние были правы, и
современная наука подтверждает пагубное
влияние раздутого эго. Наше эго создаёт
когнитивные искажения или
систематические ошибки мышления, которые
часто связаны с нашим
самообманом. Давайте посмотрим, какие
искажения создаёт наше эго. Эффект
сверхуверенности. Пожалуй, самый
известный трюк нашего эго. Люди склонны
переоценивать свои способности. Согласно
исследованиям, 74% людей считают себя
лучше среднего, что математически
невозможно. Подобные заблуждения
встречаются в бизнесе, в финансах, в
политике, да и где угодно. Слепое пятно
предвзятости. Мы замечаем ошибки других,
но не замечаем своих. Исследование
показало, что
99,8% участников считали себя менее
предвзятыми, чем окружающие. Как
правило, чем больше человек уверен в
своей объективности, тем меньше он
воспринимает критику.
Самоуслужливый биз или баяс
по-английски. Это когда успех мы
приписываем себе, а неудачи
обстоятельствам. Это защищает нашу
самооценку, но мешает нам расти.
Признавать ошибки неприятно. Вот наш
мозг и выкручивается, мол, я сделал всё
правильно. Это мир несправедлив.
Руководитель, обвиняющий рынок в
провале, не учится на своих ошибках.
Спортсмен, винящий судью, никогда не
улучшит свою технику. Эффект
подтверждения заставляет нас искать
только ту информацию, которая
подтверждает нашу точку зрения,
игнорируя неудобные факты. Эффект
контроля это вера, что мы можем
контролировать то, что объективно нам не
подвластно. Например, игрок в казино
убеждён, что у него есть какая-то
секретная стратегия обыграть рулетку.
Почему? Потому что наше эго любит
ощущение могущества. Эффект Данинга
Крюгера. Он показывает, что чем меньше
знания, тем больше у человека
самоуверенность. Невежественные люди
переоценивают свои способности, а
знающие склонны сомневаться. Проще
говоря, чем меньше компетенций, тем
громче понты. Инвестормиллиардер
миллиардер Рейдалио называет эго главным
врагом хороших решений. Оно мешает
признавать ошибки и воспринимать
критику. Таким образом, современная
наука лишь разложила по полочкам то, о
чём предупреждали нас
мудрецы. Эго искажает наше восприятие,
рождая мнимую уверенность, иллюзии и
ошибки. Убери эго, уберёшь огромное
количество ошибок мышления и будешь
ближе к реальности. Эго руководителей
часто становится причиной краха
компании. Рассмотрим три примера. Энрон,
энергетический гигант, рухнувший в 2001
году. Культура высокомерия во главе с
SEO Джефом Скиллингом привела к сокрытию
долгов и финансовым махинациям.
Высокомерие и чрезмерная гордыня
толкнули руководство на рискованные
схемы, пока реальность не обрушила
компанию Nokia. В 2000х годах она
доминировала на рынке мобильных
телефонов, но потеряла позиции из-за
отказа адаптироваться к смартфонной
революции. Руководство не восприняло
всерьёз угрозу от iPhone и Android,
считая, что они никому не нужны,
безкнопочные телефоны. В итоге Nokia
упустила момент и оказалась
неконкурентоспособной. В конце концов
она продала свой мобильный бизнес.
Компания WeWork, стартап, оценённый в 47
млрд долларов, рухнул из-за мания
величия его основателя Адама Ноймана. Он
тратил инвестиции на авантюры,
игнорировал финансовые показатели и был
убеждён в своей непогрешимости. Когда
инвесторы наконец поняли реальное
положение дел, IPO провалилась, компания
обесценилась, а Нойманов уволили. Это
классический случай высокомерия, когда
лидер теряет связь с реальностью.
История показывает, что эгоцентричные
руководители не слушают советов,
окружают себя подхалимами и игнорируют
риски, что введёт к раху компании.
Перефразируя инвестора Питера Кифа, в
бизнесе есть два типа людей: скромные и
те, кого вот-вот унизит рынок. С другой
стороны, смирение помогает компаниям
процветать.
Джем Колнс в своём исследовании от
хорошего к Великому выявил, что
величайшие SEO отличались личной
скромностью и профессиональной волей.
Сатья Наделла, возглавив Microsoft,
построил культуру обучения, а не
всезнайство, что помогло компании снова
занять лидирующие позиции. Waren Buffet
подчёркивает важность признания своих
ограничений. В инвестициях есть два типа
людей: смиренные и те, кого смирит
рынок. Вывод очевиден. Эгоцентризм
приводит к провалам осмирения к успеху.
Истинные лидеры ставят благо компании
выше своего тщеславия. Они признают
ошибки и готовы учиться. Я уверен, что у
вас тоже полно примеров из своей жизни,
когда это мешало вам принимать
правильное решение, в результате
которого вы приняли неправильное
решение. Поделитесь в комментариях,
будет всем интересно почитать.
Мы разобрали огромный пласт знаний от
древних мудрецов до современных
бизнес-кейсов. И везде мы видим один
мотив. Эго - это внутренний враг
рациональности и эффективности. Оно
словно фильтр, искажает поступающую
информацию, внушает ложную уверенность и
мешает нам учиться. Как справедливо
сказал Конфуций, скромность - основа
всех добродетелей, потому что без неё не
будет и мудрости.
Человек, уверенный, что всё уже знает,
закрывает себя от нового знания.
Организация, где лидеры не терпят
возражений, обречена повторять ошибки.
Зато когда эго убрано в сторону, сразу
же включается здоровое любопытство,
критичность, готовность рассмотреть
альтернативы, то есть всё, что нужно для
взвешенных решений. Конечно, полностью
избавиться от эго нельзя. Мы же не
буддистские монахи, отрешённые от своего
я. Но осознать его влияние и сознательно
уменьшить его роль в принятии важных
решений - это вполне реально. Дам вам
несколько практических принципов,
убирающих эго из процесса принятия
решений. Первое. Помните о намерении и
цели и подчиняйте им свои личные
амбиции, когда для вас важно не я
выиграл, а дело сделано правильно.
Спросите себя: что будет лучше для
компании, команды или семьи, а не для
моего эго? Второе. Опирайтесь на факты и
цифры, а не на мнение. При этом
обязательно проверяйте достоверность
источников. Третье, ищите правду, а не
подтверждение собственных мыслей. А для
этого в любых спорах и мозговых штурмах
специально приглашайте оппонентов или
назначайте для этого адвоката дьявола,
который будет защищать только
противоположную точку зрения. И
задавайте им вопрос: где я могу
ошибаться?
Рейдалио советует практиковать
радикальную открытость. Искренне верьте,
что вы можете чего-то не знать и активно
добывайте недостающую
информацию. Четвёртое. Признавайте
ошибки и благодарите за критику. Это
нелегко для эго, но невероятно ценно.
Сознательно говорите: "Спасибо, что
указал мне на ошибку". Это обезоруживает
ваше эго и превращает каждую ошибку в
урок, а не в травму.
Пятое. Практикуйте эмпатию и широкую
перспективу. Попробуйте представить, как
выглядит ситуация с точки зрения другого
человека. Эта перспективная гибкость
часто вскрывает слепые зоны. Недаром
Далайлама знаменито как-то сказал:
"Когда ты прав, нет нужды
кричать". Спокойная уверенность
приходит, когда ваше решение учло все
стороны, а не только ваше
эго. Шестое. В обсуждениях отделяйте
идеи от авторов, чтобы у авторов не было
нужды защищать свои идеи всеми
силами. Седьмое. Привлекайте
независимого модератора для
обсуждений. Восьмое. Нанимайте людей
умнее себя. Девятое. Старайтесь по
возможности принимать коллективные
решения. Десятое. Имейте
структурированный регламент обсуждений
для того, чтобы высказались все и у всех
были равные возможности. Надеюсь, я вам
дал достаточно информации о том, что
дегоизация - это мощный инструмент
развития. Она подкреплена религией,
философией, подтверждена наукой и
проверена практикой. Конечно, работать
над собой непросто, но, как говорил
Сократ, я знаю, что ничего не знаю. И
именно в этом его величие. Что
дальше? Инструментов и алгоритмов того,
как убрать из эго из процесса принятия
решений, очень много. Если тема вас
зацепила, не останавливайтесь на
достигнутом. Я лишь поверхностно
коснулся множества идей. За каждым из
них стоят книги, исследования и техники.
Продолжайте изучение этой темы. А если
вы хотите системно прокачать навык
рационального мышления и принятия мудрых
решений, то можете пройти мою преминую
программу Акмы для бизнесменов, уже
достигших больших успехов, но желающих
добиться выдающихся результатов. Если вы
сами не подходите под эту категорию, то
поделитесь этим видео с ними, и они
оценят вашу заботу. На этой программе я
подробно разбираю методы дегоизации,
провожу практические упражнения и
помогаю проработать ваши индивидуальные
когнитивные барьеры. Подробности
программы по ссылке
внизу. Если вам понравилось это видео и
вы почерпнули что-то ценное, поставьте
лайк, подпишитесь на мой Telegram-канал,
где я регулярно делюсь своими мыслями.
Спасибо за просмотр. И помните слова
мудреца: склонившийся получает
возможность быть
наполненным. Принимайте решение с умом,
а не с эго. Успехов вам и до встречи в
следующих выпусках.
[музыка]